[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
man wusste nur sie ist grauenhaft zu
gerichtet der Gerichtsmediziner hat
später im Prozess gesagt so sehen
normalerweise nur Leichen aus die von
einem Zug überrollt worden sind also sie
war komplett entstellt der Schädel war
zertrümmert das klang schon direkt nach
einer Tat entweder eines Wahnsinnigen
eines Psychopathen oder eben voller Hass
voller Wut
bildchef Reporter Frank Schneider
unterstützt uns heute mal wieder bei
einem Fall und dieser Fall erschütterte
das Städtchen Rees in
Nordrhein-Westfalen im Frühjahr 2009 ich
bin Toni Heyer und ich bin Mirko Kasimir
hallo und was wir euch schon Spoilern
können das Opfer in diesem Fall starben
nicht durch irgendein bis dahin
unbekannten irren sondern durch die
eigene Familie die junge Frau starb
durch eine mordart die sprachlich schwer
zu fassen ist man nannte das bis vor
nicht allzu langer Zeit noch Ehrenmord
tut das aber zum Glück nicht mehr zu
Recht findet Frank Schneider ich glaube
das ist ganz ganz schwierig Ehrenmord
finde ich auch problematisch als Begriff
als er fast noch so ein bisschen klingt
als wenn das vernünftig ist was man da
getan hat für die Ehre gemordet so nach
dem Motto dabei ist es nichts anderes
als ganz archaische überlieferte
Vorstellung von Männern die sagen Frauen
haben diese Rechte nicht frauen können
nicht selbst entscheiden was Sie machen
möchten gerade in diesen ja
patriarchalisch geprägten Familien
häufig aus dem muslimischen Kulturraum
wo der Vater entscheidet wen die Tochter
zu heiraten hat dass sie nicht westlich
zu leben hat häufig auch die
Familienmitglieder so entscheiden und
das ist immer wieder geprägt worden als
Ehrenmorde heute sagt man eher femizide
dazu aber auch der Begriff umfasst
eigentlich nicht das Leid und Elend was
dort widerfahren ist und wenn man sich
überlegt wie ganz bewusst in Deutschland
eben für Frauenrechte gekämpft wird und
dann eben Kulturverständnis da ist bei
Familien wo Mädchen diese Chance fast
gar nicht haben
Rees mit seinen etwa 21.000 Einwohner
liegt am äußersten westlichen Zipfel
Nordrhein-Westfalens die Grenze zu den
Niederlanden ist nur einen Steinwurf
entfernt direkt am Rheinufer liegt die
malerische Altstadt von Rees am Mittwoch
dem 4 märz 2009 nimmt der Hund eines
Bauern auf einem Feldweg in Rees
Witterung auf
der Landwirt folgt dem Tier ins Gebüsch
entdeckt dort den leblosen Körper einer
jungen Frau sie ist so übel zugerichtet
dass sie nicht identifiziert werden kann
tatsächlich aber wird sich zeigen der
Leichenfund passt zu einer
Vermisstenmeldung Frank Schneider es ist
eigentlich so wie häufig Morde bekannt
werden nämlich erstmal durch einen
vermisstenanzeiges sah eine junge Frau
verschwunden hieß es und dann wurde sie
auf einem Feldweg ermordet aufgefunden
und erstmal wusste man so gar nicht was
dahinter steht sondern man wusste nur
sie ist grauenhaft zugerichtet der
Gerichtsmediziner hat später im Prozess
gesagt so sehen normalerweise nur
Leichen aus die von einem Zug überrollt
worden sind also sie war komplett
entstellt der Schädel war zertrümmert
das klang schon direkt nach einer Tat
entweder eines Wahnsinnigen eines
Psychopathen oder eben voller Hass
voller Wut das Sagen Ermittler immer
wenn jemand übertötet wird so nennt man
das dann hat jemand ganz besonders viel
Hass meistens in sich und dann sind es
persönliche Beziehungstaten
bei der Toten handelt es sich um die
20-Jährige gülsem deren Nachnamen wir
hier mit es abkürzen sie stammt aus
einer kurdischen Familie und hat noch
neun Geschwister darunter eine
drillingsschwester und einen
drillingsbruder gözem arbeitet bei
McDonald's schon in den ersten Tagen der
Ermittlungen bekommen es auch Frank
Schneider und seine Kollegen ganz eng
mit dem Fall zu tun wann hast du mir so
gar nicht was hinter der Tat steht und
dann meldete sich bei uns in der
Redaktion und das werde ich nie
vergessen ein junger Mann der sagte ich
bin der Freund von gülsem der uns
plötzlich auf Fotos zeigte von Gülsen
die bildhübsch war denn die Bilder die
am Anfang von ihr von der Polizei
rausgeben waren ein unscheinbares
Mädchen und dann tauchten plötzlich
Bilder auf Bild hübsch geschminkt eben
das andere Leben der Gülsen und das war
ihr Freund mit dem sie zusammen war und
dann kam eben heraus dass sie von dem
auch schwanger geworden war
das Kind wie sie dachte heimlich
abgetrieben hatte in Amsterdam damit es
hier keiner mitkriegt die Schwester
hatte ihr dazu geraten die war nämlich
ein Mädchen von Drillingen sie hat eine
Schwester und einen drillingsbruder
und der Freund erzählte dann das aber
sie immer die Angst hatten dass die
Familie das mitbekommen und es war eine
kurdische Familie und wenn das rauskam
hat sie immer gesagt dann bin ich tot
und plötzlich war sie weg und wurde dann
so grausam zugerichtet gefunden und der
Freund sagt uns dann eben die ist von
ihrer Familie getötet worden
dank des Freundes hat die Bildredaktion
in Essen also exklusiv spannende Details
zu einem Mordfall der Menschen weit über
die Region hinaus beschäftigt aber die
Journalisten müssen sich zurückhaltend
und damit waren wir natürlich erstmal
total geschockt wie kann das sein um die
Polizei gefragt die am Anfang sich
natürlich dann nicht in die Karten
schauen lassen wollte aber auch sagt ja
auch wir kennen diesen Zeugen und das
ist alles sehr glaubhaft aber warten Sie
mal ein zwei Tage ab tun uns einen
großen Gefallen veröffentlichen das noch
nicht so in der Form mit dem Verdacht
gegen die Familie aber das sie eben auch
ein anderes Leben hier führen wollte
dass es offensichtlich ja und hinterher
hat sich genau das was uns der Freund
erzählt hat bewahrheitet es ist so
gewesen dass sie unterlagen dieser
Klinik in Amsterdam wurde die Abtreibung
hat vornehmen lassen mit nach Hause
genommen hat und das war ja Fehler und
die sind dem Bruder in die Hände
gefallen der hat sie dem Vater gezeigt
und dann so hat das Gerichte später
entschieden sind zu der Überzeugung
gekommen der Vater dann gesagt muss
sterben weil die Familien ihre
beschmutzt ist sie war nämlich eine Mann
versprochen in der Heimat und dort muss
man auch eben sagen er wartet man die
treulichkeit und einer Mädchen was
schwanger schon war abgetrieben hat kann
diese ehrvorstellung diese
Moralvorstellung in diesem Kulturkreis
nicht mehr erfüllen und hat damit in den
Verständnis dieser Familie die Familien
ihre zerstört und dies dann nur und das
ist für uns ja gar nicht nachvollziehbar
nur wiederherstellbar wenn sie stirbt
und dann hat diese eigene Familie
beschlossen gülse muss sterben wie
aber wo hat geplant und dann ausgeführt
helfen für die Kripo beginnt die
Ermittlungsarbeit als hilfreich erweist
sich auch in diesem Fall ein Mitarbeiter
auf vier Pfoten dann hat in dem Fall das
muss man auch noch sagen eine
sensationelle Spur am Anfang verfolgt
über mantrailerhunde der mantrailerhund
ist von der Stelle wo Gülsüm ermordet
aufgefunden wurde zurückgegangen am
Flüchtlingsheim vorbei hat dort verharrt
ist dann von Flüchtlingsheim zur
Wohnanschrift und somit wusste man von
wo sie gekommen ist nämlich von zu Hause
und obwohl die im Auto gefahren sind das
ist ja häufig bei sehr guten Mantrailer
und so konnte er genau die Spur
verfolgen und das war für die Polizei
natürlich eine Riesenhilfe diesen Fall
relativ schnell aufzuklären neben der
hundespur sind es Zeugenaussagen Verhöre
Handydaten und und und und die ein
umfassendes Bild ergeben ein
erschütterndes Bild muss man sagen sie
haben sehr viel Bewegungsprofile
erstellt sie haben auch wieder dahin die
Daten erfasst sie haben
Telefonüberwachung gemacht die haben
dann natürlich die Aussage des Freundes
gehabt und später hat man natürlich dann
auch den Sohn vernommen und der Vater
hat die Tat bis zuletzt bestritten der
Bruder hat sie am Ende eingeräumt und
der Vater da immer bestritten dass er
den Auftrag gegeben hätte der Bruder hat
sich sogar noch Hilfe geholt in einem
nahen Flüchtlingsheim bei einem jungen
Mann den er kannte weil er selber der
Überzeugung war ich schaffe das alleine
nicht der Vater Yusuf S hat also
beschlossen dass seine eigene Tochter
sterben muss er hat vom Doppelleben
seines Kindes unter anderem erfahren
weil güzem Unterlagen von ihrer
abtreibungs-op in der Wohnung gelassen
hatte der Vater will den Mord aber nicht
selber ausführen sondern bestimmt seinen
Sohn da Wut zum Vollstrecker und der
wiederum denkt sich eine üble Falle aus
für seine drillingsschwester er hat
bösemann auch in eine wirkliche Falle
gelockt er hat gesagt das Fahrrad wäre
wiedergefunden worden und sie wollen das
gemeinsam abholen ist mit ihm im Auto
losgefahren hat dann noch den Freund
eingeladen und Flüchtlingsheim sind da
noch vorbei gefahren und sind dann auf
einen einsamen Feldweg Abend im Dunkeln
und dort hat er dann sie erst gewirkt
und damit einem Ast so lange auf sie
eingeschlagen bis sie einfach nicht mehr
wiederzuerkennen weil sie richtig ihren
Schädel zertrümmert und den letzten Ast
man muss es so erzählen wie grausam es
war hat er mehr oder weniger in ihrem
Kopf gebohrt als sie Augenhöhlen waren
gebrochen der Kiefer war gebrochen also
er hat sie einfach komplett übertötet
und zerstört weil der Hass irgendwo da
war dass sie jetzt schuld ist dass er
auch diese Tat begehen musste also man
hat am Ende das Gefühl er war mehr oder
weniger sauer auf seine Schwester auch
immer noch weil er doch jetzt für die
Familie sie umbringen musste weil sie
die Familien ihre Beschmutzung er sucht
seine mit reingezogen wurde besonders
schlau hat sich die Familie beim Mord
nicht angestellt und so kann noch im
gleichen Jahr am Landgericht Kleve der
Prozess gegen Vater und Sohn beginnen
wildreporter Michael Engelberg schreibt
am 29 dezember 2009 folgenden Artikel
der Ehrenwort von Rees harte Strafen für
gülsems Killer da Wut erst 20 sitzt in
sich zusammengesunken auf der
Anklagebank des Landgerichts sein Blick
geht ins Leere neben ihm sein Vater
Yusuf S50 er zeigt gar keine Regung ob
die beiden begriffen haben was vor
wenigen Augenblicken passiert ist und
werden sie jemals begreifen was für ein
unfassbares Verbrechen sie begangen
haben der Prozess um den sogenannten
Ehrenmord von Rees ist vorbei die Männer
die ihre Schwester ihre Tochter bösem so
furchtbar brutal ermordeten müssen für
lange Zeit ins Gefängnis die Urteile 9
Jahre und sechs Monate Jugendstrafe für
David es wegen Mordes lebenslang für
Vater Yusuf wegen Mordes ein dritter
Mann Komplize Miro m 32 bekommt
siebeneinhalb Jahre Haft wegen Beihilfe
zum Mord 10 Monate nach der Tat sind
sich die Richter sicher Vater und Sohn
planten gemeinschaftlich den Tod der
jungen Frau
so weit der damalige bildartikel bleibt
die Frage ob die Täter im Laufe des
Prozesses überhaupt begriffen haben was
ihr Verbrechen bedeutet Frank Schneider
ja der Bruder hat schon ein Stück weit
immer das Gefühl vermittelt es irgendwo
auch sauer dass jetzt gülse mir sowas
gemacht hat sie war ja auch seine
drillingsschwester ist ganz besondere
Bindung also er sah immer noch so sie
hat auch die Familie zerstört sie ist
sozusagen auch mit Schuld aber trotzdem
hat er die Tat bereut in meiner
Wahrnehmung der Vater überhaupt nicht
der Vater hat auch das weiter bestritten
und will davon nichts gewusst haben der
war gefühlt eiskalt und hat nie Reue
gezeigt also die Schuld sah er immer bei
seiner Tochter für den Bildreporter
liegt darin die zweite Ungeheuerlichkeit
neben dem eigentlichen Mord dass der
Patriarch die eigene Tochter zum Tode
verurteilt und den Sohn so zum Mörder
macht das ist so dieses perfide er den
Auftrag gegeben sich die Finger aber
selber nicht schmutzig gemacht es ist
häufig so dass der Jüngste in der
Familie diese Tat begehen muss weil er
die mildeste Strafe bekommt und am Ende
hat das Gericht das aber auch so erkannt
der Sohn ist nach Jugendstrafe gefordert
worden hat knapp zehn Jahre bekommen der
Vater aber lebenslang als Auftraggeber
und ich finde es zeigt womit genau so
ein Typ wie der Vater an diesem Fall
einfach mal gar nichts zu tun hat und
zwar mit Ehre ja wir können ja auch mal
nachschauen was ihre eigentlich bedeutet
denn laut Wörterbuch bedeutet Ehre
ansehen und Wertschätzung durch andere
Menschen und weil Wikipedia sorry dass
ich mal wieder Wikipedia zitiere heißt
es Ehre sei ein verdienter
achtungsanspruch und genau den ja ganz
klar verwirkt man mit einem so
archalischen Mord das meint auch Frank
Schneider man kommt zwar nach
Deutschland lebt hier aber möchte dann
die kulturvorstellung aus dem eigenen
Land hierhin importieren und das
funktioniert für die Mädchen natürlich
sie möchten das Kopftuch ablegen sie
möchten leben wie in die jungen Mädchen
hier leben sie möchten sich ihren Freund
aussuchen häufig sind sie dann schon in
der Heimat versprochen und das ist immer
das Hauptproblem sie müssen jungfräulich
sein und sie müssen sozusagen dem
versprochenen Mann auch bewahrt werden
in der Heimat manchmal wollen die
Familien auch dass die Frauen dann wenn
sie erwachsen sind die Heimat
zurückkehren und dort jemanden heiraten
den sie gar nicht kennen der auch
falsche Wertvorstellungen in den Augen
der jungen Frauen haben und da prallen
dann diese kulturellen Welten
aufeinander die dann leider immer wieder
man kann da nicht von Einzelfällen
sprechen leider immer wieder zu diesen
grausamen Tötungsdelikten führen aber
ich finde wir müssen hier am Ende
unbedingt festhalten femizide sind keine
muslimische Eigenart in der
Vergangenheit wurde leider oft in den
Medien unterteilt in Tat von nicht
deutschen ist gleich Ehrenmord bringt
jedoch ein deutscher Mann seine
Partnerin um dann ist es eine Beziehung
Tat da hat sich mittlerweile schon viel
getan um eben dieses Stück mal
aufzubrechen femizide sind aber immer
noch ein riesen Problem laut der
Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung
wird in Deutschland alle drei Tage eine
Frau wegen ihres Geschlechts vom Partner
oder Ex Partner getötet vielen Dank Toni
da stimme ich dir auf jeden Fall zu denn
jeder femizid ist einer zu viel
und damit sind wir am Ende unserer
heutigen Ausgabe vielen Dank an Frank
Schneider und Stefan Netze waren für das
Skript und vielen Dank auch an dich
liebe Toni für Aufnahme und schnitt wir
freuen uns wenn ihr auch beim nächsten
Mal wieder mit dabei seid euer Mirko und
eure Toni